le conseil européen de la recherche fait
partie intégrante du premier pilier
excellence scientifique du nouveau
programme de recherche et d'innovation
de la commission européenne horizon 2020
le conseil européen de la recherche a
comme principale activité de soutenir
les carrières de chercheurs indépendants
excellent dans tous les domaines
scientifiques il fut instituée
officiellement le 27 février 2007 il est
autonome depuis 2009
son président est jean pierre
bourguignon l'objectif est d'identifier
les meilleures idées et de retenir les
meilleurs cerveaux en europe en leur
conférant un statut et une visibilité
tout en attirant des talents étrangers
le jury est international est constitué
de scientifiques
il est très sélectif enjeux forts en
matière d'excellence et de budget le rc
propose trois types de bourses starting
grant subventions destinées aux jeunes
chercheurs de toutes nationalités
possédant entre 2 ans et 7 ans
d'expérience depuis l'obtention de leur
doctorat avec un parcours scientifique
très prometteur consolidateur grant
subventions destinées aux chercheurs de
toutes nationalités
possédant entre 7 ans et 12 ans
d'expérience depuis l'obtention de leur
doctorat et enfin advanced grant sans
limite d'âge
elle concerne tous les domaines
scientifiques de l'ingéniérie et du
monde universitaire la france a le
meilleur taux de succès aux versets 674
grande île ont été attribués pour 1,3
milliard d'euros
les mrc sont vraiment un emblème de la
qualité scientifique d'une institution
aujourd'hui si on regarde le périmètre
de paris saclay il ya un peu plus de 100
lauréats versées sur les sept premières
années
2 le rc notre espoir c'est que dans les
cinq à dix ans qui viennent
cet indicateur 7,7 marque de succès que
sont les versets augmente
progressivement dans notre périmètre de
l'université paris 7 et je suis toujours
très content d'aller son terrain de
rencontrer des lauréats de l'horaire
c'est parce que c'est toujours à être
important de confronter à la diversité
de les pratiques de la recherche
donc là le nra pour la première fois
recevait un l'oréal de hercé donc
c'était une occasion pour l'institution
de célébrer une scène façon mais aussi
pour moi de voir qu'un organiste
finalisé comme le nerrant a tout à fait
sa place pour recevoir des lauréates de
verser parce que il intègre de la
science jusqu'à des produits
technologiques